مثل رائع في الحب والعطاء ضربته زوجه
مصريه تدعى هبه عطيه بعد ان احدد زوجها
قطعه من جسدها هبه لم تتردد لحظه واحده
لانقاذ حياه شريك حياتها بعد زواج 17 عاما
رغم علمها منذ فتره الخطوبه باضافته
بفيروس سي الى انها لم تتخلى عنه وتزوجته
وانجبت منه اربعه ابناء لكن طول فتره
زواجها كان الزوج يعاني من ورم بالكبد
وقام باستئصاله لكن بعد العمليه تدهورت
حالته الصحيه جدا وحدث تليف بالكبد رفض
اقرب المقربين التبرع له فاصرت الزوجه على
ان تتبرع له بجزء من كبدها وجاءت انسجتها
مطابقه تماما لانسجته لتكون سببا في انقاذ
حياته لي يا شيخه معنا
[موسيقى]
تحصل عمليه زراعه الكبد الكبد الذي لم يعد
يعمل كما ينبغي ويصاب بما يسمى فشل الكبد
يتم استبداله بكبد سليم متبرع متوفي عاده
لكن عدد الاشخاص الذين ينتظرون عمليه
زراعه كبد يتجاوز بكثير عرضك بعد
المتبرعين المتوفين ويمثل تلقي جزء من
الكبد من متبرع حي بديلا عن انتظار توفر
كبد متبرع متوفي لان الكبد البشري يتجدد
ويعود الى حجمه الطبيعي ويؤدي وظيفته
الطبيعيه بعد فتره وجيزه من الاستئصال
الجراحي لجزء من العضو عمليات الزرع من
متبرع هي لها نتائج جيده لكن العثور على
متبرع حي قد يكون صعبا يخضع المتبرعون
بالكبد الاحياء لتقييم المكثف للتاكد لمده
طابوقهم مع طلق الاعضاء صحتهم البدنيه
والعقليه وبحسب ما يقلين غالبا ما يحضر
اشخاص الذين يتلقون كبدا من متبرع حي
بمدلاء بمعدلات نجاه اعلى على المدى
القصير مقارنه القوم كبدن من متبرع متوفي
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى محافظه الشرقيه في مصر ويضام
الينا كل من الزوجه هبه عطيه وزوجها احمد
عبد الحميد يسعد صباحكم هبه واحمد والف
حمد لله على سلامتكم معا هبه خليني ابلش
معك امام مهما كان كل انسان امامه شخص
بحبه الى انه في عندنا انانيه نوعا ما
انانيه ايجابيه عندما يتعلق الامر
بالابناء بنقول بنعطيهم عيوننا لكن عندما
يتعلق الامر بالزوج هل فكرتي اكثر من مره
وترددتي
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اهلا بحضرتك
تماما
لان الزوج برده ربنا بيقول لو امرت على
الزوج ان
تجدد لزوجها
بالذات في حاله انقاذ حياته من الموت
واعادته للحياه مره اخرى
طيب احمد انت طلبت من زوجتك بانه بامكانها
انه تتبرع ولا الفكره ما كانت بالحسبان
بالاول
ولا لانها كانت ضعيفه يعني شكلها كده
نحيفه
وظيفه وكنا الحاله بتاعتك كانت ميؤوس منها
وكنا بنقول انه نحن عايزينها تبقى علشان
العيال
يعني تربي عيالها كنا خايفين عليها وكده
يعني
حتى العيله عندنا رفضت قال خلي انت انتهيت
كده
وخلي الوليه تربي العيال
لكن هي اصرت انها تتبرع
والحمد لله ربنا كلنا بالنجاح طيب احمد
انت لجات لمقربين لالك ورفضوا ممكن تقول
لنا شو كان موقفهم شو كان تبريرهم وانت
كيف اتعملت مع هذا الموقف
التبريرهم ان الدكاتره بتعلموا فيكم
وزراعاته خلصان وحالتك منتهيه خالص
وتعبانه
[موسيقى]
لان الحاله الصحيه كانت تعبانه جدا
واستسقى كبير عالي
وصحه تعبانه خالص يعني لك ان تتخيلي مش
كنت قادر اكل حبات طعميه او شويه فول كنت
بروح مطعم الفول وطعميه ده اشم ريحه بس
لكن ما اقدرش اكل حاجه خالص صحيا تعبان
جدا
فمدام هي اللي وقفت جنبي بس لكن ما لقيتش
اي حد من القرايب ولا من هنا ولا من هنا
ولا اي حاجه خالص طيب اليوم طمنيني على
صحتك بالاول كيف صحتك
والله الحمد لله في نعمه كبيره
الحمد لله والشكر لله في نعمه كبيره والله
طيب هبه اليوم في كثير اصوات وناس عمالهم
بدعوا لتوجهوا انه يتبرعوا بالاعضاء اما
خلال الحياه مثلا واحد بيقدر يتبرع بكليه
او بالكبد مثل ما انت عملتي او كمان بعد
الوفاه لقدر الله انت من مناصرها هاي
الفكره يا هبه
اه طبعا طبعا
فكره التبرع بتهب الانسان المريض حياه
جديده
بتنقذه من الموت
بترجعه لاولاده ثاني طبعا المده تعرف ربنا
ما فيش كلام فيه بس ربنا بيسبب الاسباب ان
الانسان يقدر
الانسان يقدر يساعد الانسان المريض ربنا
يرجى شفائه عن طريق الانسان اخر
طيب احمد زوجتك هبه وصفوها بالزوجه
الاصيله زوجه النبي يعني في هذا الدار من
الحب والوفاء والعطاء يعني تستحق الشكر
والتقدير اليوم شو بتقول لها بتوجه لها
كلام وشكر امام الناس يعني كتقدير على ما
فعلته
والله هي احنا بنقول ان الدنيا متاع وخير
متاعها الزوجه الصالحه فانا باشكرها شكر
جزيل
ومش عارف يعني يعني مش قادر اوصف كميه
المشاعر والحب لها قد ايه يعني
هل تعتقد انه زاد الحب وزاد التقدير بينكم
بعد اللي صار
وهي اساسا بنت ناس طيبين
اه طبعا ولا يمكن ازعلها
هي وهبتني الحياه كامله
مره ثانيه
طب هبه بالمقابل انت في يوما ما ممكن
اثناء خلافات زوجيه عايرين تقولي له بس
انا تبرعت بكبد لالك
لا ربنا ما يجيب اي خلاف ان شاء الله
وبعدين انا ما عملتش حاجه بايديا ده دي
كلها دي كلها تقدير ربنا وتوجهات ربنا
وفي اي اسلوب حياه معين اليوم عم تتبعوه
بعد العمليه سواء لك او لاحمد
والله احنا ماشين حياتنا طبيعيه الحمد لله
بس احمد بياخذ ادويه للمناعه عشان طبعا
العمليه خطيره وكده
وبنتابع تحاليل واش تحاليل مع الدكاتره
دائما
والحمد لله احمد في اي كلمه اخيره حابب
تحكي لنا اياها
ويرزقه من حيث لا يحتسب
اكيد احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر كل من زوج
هبه عطيه وزوجها احمد عبد الحميد شكرا لكم